>>commentator: So I wanna start by thanking
Natan Sharansky for coming to Google, and
he is gonna be giving us some, a talk and
we're gonna have some question and answer.
And I'm gonna give a few highlights of his
background, but not too many because I know
Natan's story of his background will be much
more exciting than me repeating it now.
But I will say that Google and Natan Sharansky
share a lot of things in common.
So the first thing I'll say is that he graduated
with a degree in computer science. So you
are in good company here; probably about more
than half the company probably has a degree
in computer science or something close to
it. So you're in the company of friends.
And the second thing I'll say about Natan
Sharansky is, well I first heard about him
when I was a-a kid in-in the 80s as really
being one of the foremost dissidents and spokesperson
for Soviet Jewry. So for really anyone living
here, this was a huge initiative for us and
I certainly heard a lot about him, and he
did a great job of putting a face to the Soviet
Jewry there.
But kind of how that relates to Google is
he has really been an-an advocate for human
rights; for speaking his mind. And I think
Google shares those two common characteristics
in our company culture.
So anyone here who works here knows that everybody
here speaks their mind; sometimes that's a
challenge to get things done. And the company
has a very, very deep commitment to human
rights. I think probably illustrated most
recently by what we, our statement with China.
And he also has, he has done a number of really
important things. After leaving Russia in
term, especially being in four successive
Israeli governments, which I'll sure you'll
hear more about and being an author.
One of them is very close to our company motto;
it's a variant of it. Our-our motto is, well
one of them is, "Do No Evil," and his is,
"Fear No Evil."
So I see a lot of commonality here between
the company and Natan.
So I welcome you to hear all your thoughts,
questions, or anything we can answer for you.
I would like to start by thanking the Jewish
Community Federation for hosting and sponsoring
the visit to the Bay Area, and I would like
to invite Jennifer Gorovitz to come up here
and say a few words, and then we'll kick off
with Natan's talk.
Thank you.
[pause]
>>Jennifer Gorovitz: Thank you.
[applause]
I'm not gonna use the chair because my feet
clearly won't touch the ground.
[laughter]
[pause]
It's wonderful to be with all of you. We're
grateful that you have us here today.
I wanna thank Susan and Dennis for your gracious
hospitality.
This is really a-a fitting place for us to
be today. Fitting because Google has been
such a revolutionary and a change agent, and
Natan Sharansky has been a revolutionary and
a change agent for all of his adult life and
is truly responsible for saving or improving
more than a million lives.
It's also fitting because a year ago, when
I assumed this role, our leaders began to
say and have consistently said since that
time, "Jen the Federation really needs to
be like Google: nimble, adaptive, visionary,
a connector to the utmost degree."
So I thank you for setting this benchmark
for me.
I'm currently leading the Federation through
a strategic reinvention with you very much
in mind.
In the meantime I thank you for making it
infinitely easier for people to find us and
all that we do and to connect with one of
our many community building groups either
online, in person, or both.
Federation, for those of you who may not know,
was created 100 years ago to solve the most
significant Jewish challenge of the day. Then,
in 1910, it was a massive immigration of thousands
of Jews with five dollars or less in their
pockets; my great grandfather included.
There were brand new social welfare organizations
and the need for very significant fund raising,
collaboration, and organization for the community
as a whole.
In 1910, remember, Jews had never been fully
accepted in any society; never completely
safe anywhere they landed. By then, it had
become very clear that we are stronger when
we are organized and that we need to care
for our own anywhere that they may be.
Couple that with the Torah's 32 references
to the Mitzvah of Tzedakah, social justice,
and the 18th century rabbinic convention of
Tikkun Olam, the imperative to repair not
just the Jewish world but the broader world
in which we live and these became the pillars
of the Federation; solving big challenges
and working as a community foundation to strengthen
community.
Year after year, decade after decade, enormous
issues continued to face the Jewish community
as well as the rest of the world and Federation
was always and continues to be the first responder.
We have always been there to make sure the
community is safe, strong, vibrant, including
through two world wars, The Great Depression,
the Holocaust, Israel's independence and five
wars, and ongoing terrorist threats through
today.
Beginning in the 1970s the Bay Area community
took on the human rights and immigration issues
of Soviet Jews, and after years and years
of local sit-ins, demonstrations, trips to
the former Soviet Union, and a campaign locally
that raised 29 million dollars in support
of a one billion dollar national effort, Natan's
dream and the dream of a million Soviet Jews
was realized to leave the former Soviet Union
and to live freely and openly without fear,
hunger, imprisonment, or injury.
This year in addition to celebrating our 100th
anniversary, we celebrate the 20th anniversary
of this incredible rescue and relocation effort;
one that involved so many of this community's
leaders very intimately.
Throughout these many years, Federation, in
its dual role as the ongoing philanthropic
engine for vibrant Jewish life and a caring
community, has done this in two ways.
First, raising over 20 million dollars annually
to invest in the community to strengthen Jewish
life here, in Israel, and around the world,
and also through the Center of Philanthropy,
which I'll talk about in just a moment.
Annually we invest in specific portfolios:
First Engagement. We open as many doors as
possible to Jewish living, remove as many
barriers to access including those that make
Jewish life not affordable for many people,
and focus on youth education and young adult
philanthropy.
For example, a few years ago, we made our
largest endowment gift of 10 million dollars
to build the local Taube Koret Campus for
Jewish Life.
In the last year alone, we granted more than
1.6 million dollars in scholarships for our
day schools and camps.
And we have just launched a venture style
philanthropy initiative in which 21 to 45
year olds will connect with each other to
select among their peers the very best models
of innovative Jewish living. This sector,
the key ingredient for Jewish connections
and continuity, garnered an investment from
us of about 10 million dollars of annual funds
this year.
Second, Israel and overseas.
There we strengthened Democracy in Israel,
build bridges during a time of increasing
isolation, and care for Jews everywhere around
the world.
This is a time not to shy away from Israel's
complex issues, but to educate ourselves and
to find ways to help. We do this work by making
it possible to send as many kids as we can
on birthright trips; these are free trips
for young adults to Israel.
By populating all of our Northern California
college campus-campuses with Shalichim, that
is young adults who come from Natan's organization,
Jafi, to work through our Hillels and by funding
disadvantaged youth and elderly in Israel.
We also work on pluralism by creating leaders
in Israel who will strengthen tolerance in
Israeli society. This sector garnered an investment
last year of more than 4.3 million dollars.
And finally, our third sector, creating a
caring community of Jews especially for those
who would be virtually invisible; those Jews
who live in poverty in the Bay Area, the former
Soviet Union, and in Israel; single parent
families, children with special needs, and
the elderly poor. In this sector, we also
invested 4.3 million dollars this year.
And second, as I mentioned earlier, we are
really a center of philanthropy providing
donor involved solutions that are tax efficient;
provide great investments; and provide a staff
of experts to advise on the philanthropic
vision, mission, and values of each donor
and to research the world's charities so that
we can facilitate philanthropy to any public
charity one could imagine.
We appreciate that in this era of globalization
and nearly complete Jewish integration, our
efforts to help anyone, anywhere in the world
are just as much our imperative as insuring
that the Jewish community is strong.
The JCF enables the individual to leverage
his or her own dollars for good through collaboration
with us, with other funders, and with networks;
the leverage that comes from acting as an
interconnected group.
The Jews as a people have always seen themselves
as a global people through time and space
just as many philanthropists have come to
view themselves as global in their orientation
through time and space.
And so the Federation, as a community foundation,
construe the world in this way too. As a connector,
a convener, a collaborator, and a leveraging
resource, we really do have something in common
with Google.
I know it's a stretch, but we're trying.
[laughter]
The message of the Federation is that each
and every one of us plays a vital role in
a collective that has the power to have enormous
impact on our community and on our world.
In our own individual ways, acting on our
own values, thinking creatively, strategically,
and generously through an annual community
investment, through a donor advised fund,
or through an endowed fund, we are part of
a powerful and generous interconnected community
We are all in this together to save lives,
to improve lives, and to transform lives.
That's the power of our Federation community;
one that manages and stewards over one billion
dollars of assets and last year granted more
than 154 million dollars all over the world
from our annual fund, our 900 plus donor advised
funds, and our 70 foundations and endowed
funds.
A thriving community needs many things: great
vision, financial investment, builders, sustainers,
a thick web of connection, and heart.
We are here to make sure that all of these
ingredients come together for joy, for meaning,
for family, for continuity from generation
to generation.
Please join me in welcoming Natan Sharansky,
our featured speaker today.
[applause]
>>Natan Sharansky: Thank you.
Well I'm very glad to be here and thank you
for my introduction where it was said that
we have something in common that I was implied
in the semantics that we follow with this
parallel.
In fact it was a more powerful parallel because
I, when I, when I was a school child in Soviet
Union the first Soviet computers appeared;
it was in the 60s.
And the first computer that I was working
on was doing one hundred operations per second;
it was all on, built on radio bulbs; it was
before transistors; so these bulbs, so in
fact the speed of the computer was defined
with the speed with which you can replace
the bulbs because they were broken all the
time.
[laughter]
And with this technology, then I went to one
of a very prestigious Soviet university became
a special in the department of medicine as
it was in my master degree that I invented
the first chess program, computer program
to play chess – Anspiel files; the Anspiel
chess games.
It was then the first attempts of writing
such programs and Anspiel was especial difficult
because well the all the al-algorithms then
were based on your analyzing the tree of all
possible developments and then you compare
them, or you have to count up to them, what
was then simply impossible or you have to
have some kind of comparison based on some
criterias. And at the end of the game, those
who know chess it is, was especially difficult.
And so I created the semantical program which
was dealing with artificial intellect which
tried not only to have formal comparison but
tried to have some logical the battle; how
you building strategy; go from the beginning
to the end then you go from the end to the
beginning and then again I will not into the
details, but really I tried to simulate the
building of the strategy by in a, in a logical
way.
And I was very proud of it. It was written
on the first time you have this end game.
And then I was arrested and I spent nine years
in prison and when I was released though I
while in prison and punishing and in solitary
confinement, I had a lot of experience of
playing chess in my head with myself and I
won all these games --
[laughter]
but here I didn't an ability to improve my
what was computer program so though, after
nine years that I was in prison, four generations
of computers were born and died.
So I went into the absolute new world; it
was just, there were personal computers, it
was absolute different there. So I assumed
there was no way that I can compete and all
my powerful program already had no meaning
because it appeared a few years after this
real powerful search engines like Google which
denied all what I was doing. In fact they
simply ignored all this. [chuckles]
[laughter]
And-and so I decided there is, that I really
have to change my profession so I didn't go
back [ ] and simply enjoying them as a client
of Google and these great things that you
are doing.
Now the second thing which I wanted to say
and I am glad that it was said in the beginning,
in fact I was very pleased, I tried to send
my personal appreciation to the head of Google
who worked for the position that you took
in China. Because the one who spent a lot
of years in struggling for freedom and democracy
and then in the last years trying to build
international support of democratic dissidents
all over the world.
I organized big international conference of
democratic dissidents you will see Garry Kasparov
just saw one of my good friends, but people
like him acting in China, in Egypt, in Syria,
and many other countries. And I know from
my experience and their experience how international
solidarity is important and how betraying
is the behavior of those people in the free
world who are ready to cooperate with all
the dictators of the world only to have their
business. And all those explanations if you
will not do it, somebody else will do it.
And about China, I've heard it from many businessmen.
And it was also very upsetting to see how
this great weapon of freedom which was invented.
In our times when we were dissidents in the
former Soviet Union there were no CNN and
no Internet and it was so easy to authorities
to cut us from all the world. It was so difficult
to bring information to the, to the citizens
of the Soviet Union which we were doing through
in a very difficult ways through foreign radio
stations by risking the lives of many people.
And here we have Internet; here we have such
powerful weapon and which is used if you know
Iranian dissidents it was one of their main
weapons.
So and then this Internet is used by secret
police to dis, to-to discover their political
opinions and to repress them. That was very
painful and disappointing. And so I'm very
glad that Google became pioneer in this field
and I can only hope that in spite of many,
many business, businessmen who think that-that
making business is the best contribution to
peace and that well let's ignore all this
moral restrictions that in fact the example
Google will be broadened, supported, and that's
something extremely important. And for this
you-you deserve a lot of credit in addition
to the fact that you invented search engine
which destroyed all my theories which I was
building before --
[laughter]
I went to prison.
Okay.
Now let's talk about the topic that I really
feel myself; special statement and that's
?
[pause]
freedom fighting against dictatorship, and
what is the source of the power which they
are getting.
And the, I, based mainly on my personal experience.
Well I see for good and for bad most of you
are so young that you have no idea what in
the world is Communism.
But there was a regime which technically was-was
taking one-sixth part of the earth; political
was controlling one-third of the earth; physically
it was a regime which controlled 200 million
people of the, citizens of the former Soviet
Union.
And it was controlling not only their-their
physical life, but their minds. In fact, the
regime which ideologically in the beginning
of the 20th century came with idea that now
we are creating society of equal people, that
everybody's equal; there is no exploitation
of one or the other. But in order they will
be absolutely, completely equal there should
be no differences. And that's why they should
have no property; all the property will be
taken by the State and State will decide how
to distribute the property.
And there will no national or religious differences.
And that's why we will destroy nationalism;
we will destroy religion. Everybody has to
be loyal to our idea-ideology and not to anything
else.
And because the nature of the people was resistant
to this, so they in the beginning as Lenin
wrote, if you will have to kill bunch of capitalists
who are preventing us from having society
where everybody will be equal, so we will
have to kill them.
So they start killing from hundreds and then
thousands, and tens of thousands, hundreds
of thousands, tens-tens of millions.
Then now historians are discussing whether
the number of victims of this regime of their
own citizens was 20 million or 30 million
or 40 million; so really even difficult to-to
appreciate.
But that was the result of this attempt to
create society where there is no, everybody's
equal.
As a result I am, I was already the second
if not the third generation of absolutely
assimilated Soviet Jews. And when I was assimilated,
I lived in the big city in the Ukraine with
half a million population with at least 50,000
Jews and they knew nothing about my history,
about my holidays, about my tradition, about
anything.
More than this, I was born few years after
Holocaust in the places where hundreds of
thousands of my people and also many of my
relatives were killed and we grew knowing
nothing about Holocaust. We knew of course
about great victory of Soviet Union over Hitler,
but the fact that there were millions killed
only for being Jewish, we didn't know. It
was deprived from our knowledge; it was deliberately
done in order not to do anything which can
give us kind of all national pride, all national
desire or whatever.
And the same time we knew where it was that
we were Jewish, why? Because it is written
in the idea of your parents and there is a
lot of anti-Semitism; lot of restrictions;
all the discussion told us what is possible
not what was not possible to do.
And as a result, the message which we are
getting from our parents is that because you
are Jews, you must be the best in physics
or in the semantics or in chess or in music,
it doesn't matter in what. But you must be
the best in your profession. That's why, that's
you can go to this tower of science or what
and maybe then you'll be protected as Jews;
maybe you'll suffer less.
And that was the idea how to survive, to become
good specialists and how to survive.
And then we totally were deprived of identity,
but we also were deprived of freedom. It was
clear for us from our childhood that we live
under dictatorship.
The, I always tell the story when I became
loyal citizen simply-simply because it's,
shows in one short story, it shows immediately
what was the state of mind of Soviet people.
I was five years old when Stalin died. Though
you are young, but probably you know who was
Stalin.
And so when Stalin died, I came home from
kindergarten and my, and we lived then in
communal apartment: three, four, five families
in one apartment with one kitchen, with one
toilet, and so on.
And father making sure that neighbors don't
hear told me that Stalin was awful man; he
killed a lot of people; we Jews we are in
big danger, but now we are saved and I should
remember all my life that miracle happened,
Stalin died. But he said don't tell it to
anybody. Do what everybody does and next day
go to kindergarten and there in the kindergarten
I cried together with all children because
Stalin died and I sing song how grateful we
are to the great leader of all the people,
Stalin, who gave us such a happy childhood
that was the [ ] of the song.
So I sing it; I cry; and I remember miracle
happened I should be very happy Stalin died.
[laughter]
That is typical state of mind of loyal Soviet
citizen. It's double think. You don't believe
in this regime and with time every dictator
in the regime as I later tried to show in
my books every dictatorial regime the number
of double thinkers is growing with the time.
So they are not already true believers they
are double thinkers, but they're not dissidents.
Because dissidents are those who are crossing
this line and who are ready to risk their
life.
But to think that people cross this line and
would become dissidents, what, why to risk
a life; there is no value in this life. The
only value is how to survive; how to become
good specialists and then work in your ivory
tower and that's it. And of course you feel
yourself very uncomfortable; you don't have
any strength to fight against it.
So I was deprived of freedom, and over identity.
And I had no force to struggle for anything.
When it all changed. Two events happened,
very important.
One was in 1967 Israel emerged victorious
against its neighbors who wanted to destroy
Israel. And for Soviet Union, that was a very
big humiliation, very big humiliation. And
because Soviet Union sent a lot of money and
lot of soldiers in fact, a lot of weapons
to Syria to, and to Egypt and already started
celebrating the victory.
And so suddenly, it's all changed and you
see how for the people around you they are
changing their attitude to you; those who
like you, those who hate you.
But they connected with Israel that even anti-Semitic
jokes and there was every day, there was another
anti-Semitic joke there about different Jews.
Yesterday they were about Jews who are cowards
and who want to take money off somebody. Today
they are about Jews who are hooligans, who
are fighting, who are beating the others.
So you understand that for these people somehow,
you're connected to Israel and you want to
understand this connection. And you start
reading in the underground because there is
no way to read it publicly. From the books
which are brought mainly by tourists, American
Jews and not only American -- tourists.
And you discover there is great history which
starts from exodus from Egypt and it's so
easy to feel yourself part of that exodus
and which continues with the Exodus of Leon
Uris. And Leon Uris, if you read today it's
Bubba Meisah. It's interesting but whether
it's true or not.
But then it was such a powerful discovery
that people of our age can be part of this
great history.
And so suddenly discover this great history
and you discover there are Jews who are all
over world who feel solidarity with you. And
you feel stronger; you want to part of this
history. And that what starts giving you this
feeling that there are things more important
than your physical survival. And that what
will, what will become the big source of strength
for me to fight for my rights, for rights
of other Jews, and for the rights of many
non-Jews.
And there was another important event. Another
important event is the letter -- Andrei Sokolov.
Andrei Sokolov who at the time became a great
friend, my great leader, I would say my great
rabbi but he was not Jewish so he could not
be rabbi.
[laughter]
But-but that is, that was scientist number
one of the Soviet Union. There was nobody
even close to him. He was the father of hydrogen
bomb; he was the great, made great discoveries
in theoretical and experimental physics. From
the age of 29 he not only was the member of
academia but he had all the top Soviet awards.
There was nobody even close in com-compared
to him.
And this man ?
[pause]
published a letter; in-- it was 1968. Published
a letter to the Soviet leaders where he writes
that if Soviet leaders will not permit freedom
of thought for their citizens there is no
chance that Soviet Union will be a superpower;
because the best physics in the world, the
best mathematics in the world, the best talents,
but it-it will mean nothing if you're not
giving the freedom of discussion, the freedom
of thought to-to our citizens.
Of course they immediately changed his status;
he immediately became a dissident and he lost
all his privilege in this society.
But what it meant for me, I thought, "Look
I am trying to find the way into this castle
of science as a young scientist with my funny
programs in chess and in computers and I hope
to find the piece to my course." Here is a
person who's already on the top. He is at
the top of this ivory tower; nobody can be
higher than him.
And he feel that he cannot continue this life
of double think that we all have. That he
has to say the truth and he has to demand
the truth. And so that had tremendously powerful
influence on me. I understood that all these
attempts to find peace of mind by hiding in
the world of science impossible.
So on one hand, this understanding that it
is impossible to adjust yourself because you
have freedom of thought, and freedom of consciousness,
freedom of will. On the other hand, I discovered
my identity which gives me a lot of strength;
the strength to start fighting.
In the beginning all if I did was say publicly,
"I really don't want to live in this country
I want to leave this country." But that's,
that's -- the moment you said it you already
crossed the line. You're-you're apart, you
will lose your job, your apartment will be
searched, your, you will be called for interrogations,
many of your friends will ask you to take
their names from your telephone book because
they don't want to be, to have problems with
the secret police.
But you, but from this moment you stop having
this double life, double life which you started
in the age of five from the death of Stalin
and which you continue to this day.
And then you-you have enough strength to start
fighting for your right to immigrate and then
for the rights of the other people.
It's a moment I became the unofficial spokesman
of two movements: Soviet Jewry Movement and
human rights movement of the Soviet Union;
and was very actively working with Andrei
Sokolov and the other dissidents.
And at the same time I was very active in
the struggle of Soviet Jews to leave as Jews
and to go to Israel or to other places.
And I got to say that I remember there were
people on both sides who were telling me that
I cannot continue in this. That you really
have to choose or you are Nationalist or you
are Universalist, or you are for the rights
of that small tribe, small family which is
called Jews, or you are for the human rights
of all the world.
And I have to say I-I never felt that I have
to choose. Not only because I enjoyed being
in both of these movements, I really enjoyed
fighting the regime being in both these movement.
[laughter]
But-but because I felt there is deep connection;
that in order you have the strength to fight
for freedom of all the mankind, you must have
things which are more important for you than
your physical survival.
You must have your identity; your desire to
belong is -- that is the source of power to-to
meet your desire to-to be free.
And I believe these are two basic desires
of people: to belong and to be free. And only
when they are connected together you can have
great results.
And this, from this point, our experience
was to some extent opposite to experience
of our grandfathers of those of our grandfathers
who joined Communist Revolution. Because what
was the idea of Communist Revolution? The
idea of them many Jews decided at that moment
finally we don't have to think only about
our small tribe; about our shtetl. We can
finally fight with a great ideal of equality
and freedom for all the world; the big people
of humanity.
And those who believed in it they helped to
create one of the most awful regimes in-in
the history which killed tens of millions
of its citizens including all those naive
idealists who joined the Revolution.
For this one to be, went in the opposite direction.
We went back to our schtetl, to our tribe,
to our people, to our language, to our history.
And there we found strength to fight for the,
for the better for all the world.
I can tell you that not only in my dissident
activity but in prison my best friends were
people with strong identities. Why, because
in prison you-you-you can never know who is
the real and who is not. Because KGB succeeded
to create it was to feel it among two hundred
million people; nobody knows who is informer,
who is not.
But in prison, where they -- KGB decide with
who you will be in one cell of course they
can decide, you-you suspect everybody.
And what you find out that the bet-best way
to-to-to know something about person if this
person has strong identity of his or her own.
If this person has things for which he is
ready to die for.
My closest friend was religious, Christian
activist who was persecuted for-for teaching
Christianity to-to-to the, he actually himself
was young, but for the young people.
And in the prison, he was ready to die for
his views but not to cooperate with KGB.
So you could know that because for you, there
are things which are more important than your
physical survival and when they-they threatened
me with death sentence, you know that you
really don't want to cooperate with them because
you want to remain free and you became free
only when you found your own world.
So the-the same is to other people. That's
why Pentecostals and Ukrainian Nationals and
Armenian dissidents they were my best friends
because I knew that I can rely on them as
they can rely on me.
So this connection between freedom and identity
was very powerfully seen there.
Now the free world, we could never survive
in our struggle in one day if from the very
first day it didn't become the struggle of
all the Jews of the world and then also all
the free people of the world.
Because if we were organizing small demonstrations:
five people, for five minutes, standing in
the Center of Moscow. Why, because you couldn't
have more than five people because then KGB
will know at once and there'll be no demonstration.
You couldn't, even if KGB does know in advance
it -- you cannot stand with a slogan, "Freedom
to political prisoners," in the center of
Moscow more than five minutes be-before you're
arrested.
And then your partners, establish partnership
by years of prison and you get asked, "So
what is the sense of this stupid demonstration
for five minutes of pleasure or standing in
the center of Moscow, you're getting five
years of prison?"
But the thing is that it was organized well;
that was one-one of my obligations. Meaning
that at least one foreign journalist knows
in advance and he will come and he will inform;
and there is no Internet, there was no CNN,
but in the evening on BBC or Voice of America,
or Radio Liberty it will be broadcasted that
five Jews went on demonstration.
Next day they'll be hundreds of thousands
of Jews who will go on demonstrations; really
physically hundreds of thousands of Jews.
They will write to their senators and congressman;
they'll demand from the State Department to
protest. The Soviet ambassadors will be called
in down in street in-in Paris and in Washington,
demand.
American legislators will pass, they pass
special legislation connecting freedom of
immigration with all the trade interests of
the former Soviet Union.
And that is how the struggle was built.
KGB when we were there for a year and half
and they were interrogating me and threatening
me and so they were saying, "What are you
building your hopes on? Look who you're supporting
you; they are a bunch of students and housewives.
And we are KGB."
And they-they give good, great, gave great
definition about it. Nine years later when
I was released I went from one community to
the other to thank you, the army of students
and housewives because for 20 years this army
of students and housewives was fighting and
didn't let Soviet Union even one day of peace.
And they mobilized, of course, all the leaders
of the world.
And they were Father Drinan, too young to-to
remember there was such member of K'nesset,
member of, congressman in America, Christian,
Catholic, Father Drinan who left -- the Pope
demanded for him to resign because he said
the that Catholic leader cannot be member
of congress so unfortunately he left, he resigned.
But he was the leader who mobilized millions
of Christians for in support of Soviet dissidents.
There were many others.
By the way, we are still close to Stanford
-- Google didn't exist then. But standard
universities, Stanford University existed.
Stanford University became the center of all
of the gold Nobel Prize winners to fight for
the freedom of Soviet Jews and Soviet dissidents.
There was an organization Source organized
in Stanford University —Save Aharon Sharans.
In fact it was big scientists of the world
united to-to for the freedom of Soviet democratic
dissidents.
And I have to say that it was not easy to
struggle not only because of KGB, but because
many people in the free world believed that
Soviet Union is forever; it will never change;
and we have to know how to live in peace with
the Soviet Union.
And that's why they were saying, "Trade is
better than, when we have trade there is no-no
wars. So let us have trade with them."
Here Senator Jackson comes with the amendment
to connect all the trade agreements of United
States of America with the creation of freedom
in Soviet Union.
And even businessmen and President, then it
was Nixon, speak against it. They speak that
we don't want these restrictions. We cannot
dictate to Soviet Union what-what is freedom;
they have their own principles but we want
to live in peace with them.
And we, and Andrei Sokolov was very good with
them and he had to explain again and again
to the free world that the only way that there
will be stability and peace is if it will
support Soviet dissidents.
As long as it is a totalitarian regime, it
will need you as the enemy. So they will have
trade with you, but they will build everything
so their own people will hate you because
otherwise this regime cannot survive. And
that was a big battle.
And that's why I say that what Google is doing
now is so important.
Some days ago I published an article in support
of Nobel Prize Committee which gave the Nobel
Prize to Chinese dissident in prison.
And again if you know immediately after this
there was again voices the West, what it has
to do with peace? Why-why tell it to Chinese
people what to do?
And I -- that article I went back to the logic
was dissidents of the Soviet Union explaining
why for the security of United State of America,
it is very important what is happening with
human rights there in-in China.
So I want to say that that is in fact one
battle; one battle which continues; there
is no borders in this battle. There must be
people for whom physical survival is not the
most important thing; who have principles,
identity for which they are ready to-to-to
sacrifice everything, and who believe in freedom.
And these people have to be supported by all
the free world and that is the only way to
guarantee freedom and stability in the world.
Well I say it in about, in about 10 minutes
all my three books are about it so those of
us who want to dissent why it is better, please
go to Google find my three-three books.
One is about my experience in Soviet prison,
another is about the case for democracy, and
the third is about defending identity.
So it's all these topics together today, then
I was in Israeli governments when Prime Minister
Netanyahu proposed me again to go to politics,
I said, "No-no I was nine years in prison.
I was nine years in these early politics.
I think I have good balance.
[laughter]
I really don't want."
He asked whether I want to be in the government.
I told him, "Look, I was in four different
Israel governments and that why I resigned."
In comparison, I was in four different prisons
and never resigned. They asked me many times
to sign letter to resign and I refused to
resign.
So probably something wrong.
And then he said, "So what you want?" I said,
"I want to be chairman of The Jewish Agency."
That's why I'm the chairman of Jewish Agency.
Jewish Agency is unique organization which
tries, which is global table of Jewish people
and the Israeli government which tries to
connect between Israel and Jewish communities
all over the world.
And I know the power of this connection; I
know how this connection inspired us and gave
us strength to fight for freedom and I know
that it is also true today.
So thank you for inviting me. I'm glad to
be here and see that in two days from now
there will be a Garry Kasparov speaking. My
great friend the last, in the last, when I
gave him my last book I wrote there, "To Dissident
Kasparov from Chess Player Sharansky," –
[laughter]
'cause so the life has very interesting twists.
I am very glad that you are a place which
attracts leading democratic dissidents. They
need your support. You have a very powerful
weapon in your hands which gives opportunity
to make dissemination information much easier,
unbelievably easier.
But what the biggest problem was, was how
to reach Soviet people in the Soviet Union
with our truth, and today you have this weapon
which also can be used by our enemies.
So don't let it [ ] our enemies and keep supporting
freedom of the world.
Thank you.
[applause]
So, if-if you have any questions, I'll be
glad to answer.
Yeah, please.
>>female #1: Thank you very much for coming.
It must have been very hard along the way;
you must have had doubts. How –
>>Natan Sharansky: Um, um.
>>female #1: [unintelligible]
>>Natan Sharansky: I can amplify it up here.
>>female #1: Thank you very much for coming.
You must have had doubts along the way. How
did you maintain your focus and your ability
to com-continue going on despite how hard
it was? You must have along the line thought
it wasn't worth it.
[pause]
>>Natan Sharansky: Well, that's an interesting
question. I recommend you to read my three
books about this. [chuckles]
[laughter]
But-but briefly I'll tell you.
[pause]
It's true that it was a long and difficult
way and I think if in the beginning before
I made my first step somebody would tell me,
"That if you'll do it, you'll go to prison
and you can be sentenced to death. You'll
be accused in high treason and you will be
405 days in the punishment cell, and you will
be five years in solitary confinement, and
you'll be this, this, this" probably then
I would not do it. Probably, I don't know.
[laughter]
But it's doesn't go this way. It goes step
by step.
First, you feel yourself enslaved. Then you
discover the power of identity, and it gives
you a lot of big desire to belong to this
history and to these people. Then you discover
the power of freedom. You start saying your
mind; speaking your mind.
And it is such a powerful state of mind; you-you
really don't want to go back.
And then you're becoming part of the struggle
which becomes very important. And you really
feel yourself part of some important historical
struggle.
And then in prison, where they start proposing
you different types of compromises: big compromises
and small compromises. And you know you're,
the moment you start making their compromises,
you will lose this freedom. You really feel
yourself even in prison, you feel yourself
free person and there you are slave. You don't
want to go back.
And that of course then there is a question
of how you keep it every day. For example,
especially I was 405 days in punishment cell.
Punishment cell, by their law, you're not
supposed to be more than 15 days because you
can become crazy. It's very cold, very dark,
three pieces of bread, three cups of water,
nobody to talk to. You are supposed to become
crazy simply.
And officially it is to no more than 15 days.
I was kept 405 days there.
So first of all, every day you have to remind
yourself how important you are; that it, that
it, that you are part of that great history
and one word of you can influence and everything.
They tried to convince me that there was Galileo
Galilei such a great scientist and he cooperated
with inquisition. So who you are not to do
it? Be clear – it was Galilei.
And I was thinking, "If Galileo Galilei cooperated
with inquisition and 400 years after this
they are using it, the inquisition, using
it against me, so if I'll make any compromise
for them 400 years after this, somebody will
be using it." That's how we think.
So first of all you have to self-aggrandize
yourself.
[laughter]
On the other hand, you have to understand
that nothing is serious. You have to be able,
to be able to laugh at everything. And it's
such an idiotic organization, this KGB.
And it is so easy to make laugh of them and
you're making all this jovial, you're telling
to these KGB people anti-Soviet jokes. There
was a lot of anti-Soviet jokes which of course
we were told one, one.
And here telling them some joke about Brezhnev
and it's so funny that you, you speak and
you laugh. And you see that they are almost
exploding from desire to laugh but they cannot
laugh. They will lose their job –
[laughter]
one place or the other.
And I tell them, "And you want to say that
I'm in prison. You cannot even laugh when
you want to laugh. And you want me to be like
you."
So you're laughing while all of this [ ].
The third thing is you have to use your brains.
As I said, I had great hobby, chess; absolutely
great. I at the age of 12 I thought I'll be
world champion and then at 14 I understood
I cannot be such a [ ], number one and number
two I was not interested so I went to look
where I can be number one and it was prison.
So –
[laughter]
so, but I was playing single ten years games
and went and so I didn't know for what I am
doing it.
In prison it became sense. In punishment cell
I played thousands of games in my head. I
won all of them.
[laughter]
I, each game next day I'm improving the previous
result because then they black horse so now
I'll play this option for the black and I
improve it and so instead of being degr-degradating
intellectually I becoming better and better.
And the final, most important thing my great
other hobby was singing. And I enjoyed singing,
but the moment I start singing in the Kindergarten
the nanny says, "And you wait, you will sing
after." Because people really didn't like
what I was singing; I was destroying every
one melody. And they tried in school and summer
camp and everywhere people say, "No, please
don't, don't, don’t."
[laughter]
So finally in the punishment cell I understood
that is the moment which nanny promised that
you will sing light.
[laughter]
So in political prison where must be silence
like in grave because you are not supposed
to say, you are not supposed to know what's
happening, who else is in prison.
So I say here, "I have nothing to lose. I'm
already 400 days in punishment cell; five
years in solitary confinement."
I sing with all the power of my lungs something
very Zionist, very good. And they become crazy.
First of all they don't understand what I'm
saying in Hebrew. And second they don't enjoy
my singing.
[laughter]
And so it-it's such a pleasure. And so that's
how I sang for nine years, okay?
[laughter]
[pause]
[applause]
>>male #1: Yeah, I just wanted to thank you
again for coming and both for Googlers and-and
in honor of my father who spent the war in
Ukraine and Russia. And anyway, but thanks
for being here.
I have a question. I just recently read the
book, "Bargaining with the Devil", which has
a chapter about you. And he discusses the
fact that I guess you were offered the ability
to leave prison at any time you wanted to,
you'd have to sign something, but you could
renounce it as soon as you left the Soviet
Union and you would have been a free man.
And yet your decision was not to, not to bargain
with the devil; not to sign those papers.
Could you discuss the-the rationale behind
that?
>>Natan Sharanshy: Yeah, well again it's-it's
really it's deep one and important question.
And my first book, Fear No Evil, half of this
book is exactly about this why not to bargain
with devil. Why-why.
Let me give you all only episode because that
can-can give you a flavor of why it is also
important today.
Yes it is true that during interrogation they
were in fact hinting and even more than hinting
they're saying that, "Become a man. Say that
we are right; you are wrong. You're so young.
You're a great scientist," they were saying.
"You're so bright. You have such a beautiful
wife." An insult, that was true.
[laughter]
"So and you are ready to sacrifice all this
for what? For some views." And I felt very
strongly that the moment I do it I lose my
freedom.
And that I betray all that ideas from which
I came.
At some moment in prison already I was for
few years in prison, and I was on the long
hunger strike, hunger strike which continued
110 days where they were not letting me write
letters and then they gave up.
There was big pressure all over the world:
President Reagan, Margaret Thatcher, Mitterand;
everybody was demanding from Soviet Union
to release me.
And finally they gave up and let me write
letters. And they denies me the meeting with
my mother and I had, in nine years I had two
meeting. And she tells me later on that it
was the end of Madrid Conference, Madrid Conference
was a continuation of Helsinki process, and
there Americans put a condition that they
will not sign this agreement without my release.
And the Russians agreed that if I will sign
the letter they will write that because I
have, I am in bad health after hunger strike
and they asked Soviet Union to show human-humanism
and to release me, I will be released.
And Americans were in rapture; American two
leaders that were American delegation and
I don't want to mention their names, they
are very respectable and good people. They-they
rushed to my wife who was leading campaign
for my release and they said that they got
great agreement. Russians don't demand for
me to-to say that-that I'm criminal, don't
demand to me that they are right or wrong.
They only ask be human, I am a poor ill Jew,
release me please. And I will be released.
And they thought it big victory.
I will tell my wife, "Tell them it's bull.
There is no chance that my husband will do
it."
They were so furious. They said, "We reached
such an agreement so you have to do everything
to convince them, him."
Well my mother comes to the, they give her
special meeting in order she will tell me
conditions.
And she said, "that some dissidents think
that you can do it." I said, "I'm sure that
my wife didn't say it." Mother said, "No,
my wife, your wi, Avital said that she leaves
it to you."
And then mother said what was-was very difficult
for her. She was 75 years old; she was a big
fighter; she wanted me very much to be out
and she said, "And I am not telling you what
to do. We leave it to you." And I said, "I
don't have even to think for a moment. There
is no way that I'll sign it. There is no way
that I will give them any legitimacy to-to-to
what they did. If they want to release me
they don't, they don't need my letters. But
they want this letter in order to give some
kind of legitimacy to what they were doing."
And so I have say to this day some American
officials believe that because of some radical
views I betrayed them; President Reagan was
okay, he was okay. He continued his struggle.
But I say that then, in this clear moment
of confrontation you really feel and see it
very clearly that any moral compromise which
will give legitimacy to their right is strenthening
them and weakening in fact all this time which
you had. After all these years that you already
put it this moral plan so high and they had
such desperation they really feel themselves
pressed; they cannot decrease the pressure.
And I want to say that who knows if they decrease
the pressure then if our moral [ ] could be
weakened, if the world would stop pressure
with Soviet Union; maybe Soviet Union would
have exist until this day.
But only because some moment is becomes uncompromised
moral struggle and Soviet Union then has to
make some concessions that what they-they,
I was released, other political prisoners
was released, and then the moment regime is,
has less control, it simply fell apart; exactly
as are we are predicting.
So I-I believe that at some moment when you're
dealing with evil, if you really want that
this evil will disappear, you cannot make
a moral compromise with them.
Thank you.
[pause]
>>female #2: Hi. Thank you again for coming
to speak to us today. It was a really interesting
talk.
And one of the points that you had mentioned
was about the story of identity and kind of
freedom fighting and kind of wearing the dual
hats of both fighting for freedom for the
Jewry as well as for universally.
So I was curious you-you've been a member
of Parliament and Cabinet for a few years,
kind of what is your outlook of the Palestinian
struggle for freedom? And how Israel is going
to make that happen?
>>Natan Sharansky: Well for this, you have
to read my second book,
[laughter]
"The Case for Democracy".
But okay I'll tell you.
[pause]
I'm not big believer in the so called peace
process. The reason for this is very simple,
because all the peace process, at least until
the-the very recent times, was absolutely
disconnected from the question of democratic
reforms.
As a result from the very beginning we were,
in '93, I don't know if you were born, but
in '93 –
[laughter]
was-was-was signed, was signed Oslo Agreement.
And-and when we took Yasser Arafat who before
this was world renowned terrorist and gave
him legitimacy it brought him to Palestine.
And our Prime Minister then one week after
they sign an agreement said, "It is very good
that Yasser Arafat is a dictator and not democrat.
Because as a dictator who is not restricted
by human rights, Supreme Court, and heart
bleeding liberals," I quote, "he will fight
Hamas much better than we can do it."
That's when I wrote my first article against.
I wrote, "We will do everything to strengthen
him as a dictator, and he is a dictator in
order to survive. We'll do everything that
Palestinians will hate us because otherwise
he cannot really control his own people. And
that it should be our interests that he will
be controlled by Supreme Court, by his Supreme
Court, by his human rights organizations,
and by real heart bleeding liberals or free
press whatever was of them."
And well we know historically how, who won
in this battle; Arafat won; Hamas-Hamas won.
And so I-I do have friend, first of all I
do believe in peace in Palestinian democratic
state. I don't believe that our efforts, and
I said it to Clinton, I said it to Bush, I
said it to all our governments, and I unfortunately
I was dissident of this.
I said, "I don't believe that our attempts
to build peace with dictators ignoring the
real needs of Palestinians can bring stability."
And unfortunately each time when we were doing
this it happened to be right.
Now I do have friends, Palestinians who are
real democrats. But each time when I was trying
to bring them to the corridors of power in
Jerusalem, in Washington, or in Europe, the
most difficult was in Europe, the answer also
always was, "But how much strength these people
have? We have to deal with those who really
can control the situation. That's why we have
to deal with Yasser Arafat. That's why we
have to deal with Abu Allan and Hamas and
so on, because they have the real power."
I can speak a lot about situation with human
rights, opposing authority or the rights of
women. About the rights of gays, sometimes
I appear on campus with Palestinian gays and
with some others who can tell you a lot about
the situation. I believe that as long as we
are ignoring the real-real issues of freedom
of Palestinians, we are deceiving ourselves.
And I'll tell you from my own experience not
only when you are a man [ ] but specifically
Palestinians can be closer to democratic way
of life than maybe any other group of Muslims
because they have been in Diaspora, because
they were involved in free economy, because
through-through Israel, and because they are
so close to-to they can appreciate the real
advantages of democracy.
The fact that in the last 17 years we gave
so much power to dictators who are interested
to destroy all this democracy is only weakening
chance for peace.
But again that is my private opinion which
has nothing to do with my chairmanship of
Jewish Agency.
>>female #2: Thank you.
[laughter]
>>Natan Sharansky: Okay.
[pause]
>>commentator: It's time for one last question.
>>male #2: How did you find out that you were
going to be released from the Soviet prison?
>>Natan Sharansky: Ah. Well first of all things
that I didn't know; what I didn't know in
19, in November of 1985 there was summit,
first summit between Reagan and Gorbachev
in Geneva.
And of course my wife, as all these years,
she came there and demonstrated in front of,
together with some students and housewives
from-from New York, from Toronto, from Paris,
who came and demonstrated with her.
And she was demonstrating, she was in the
uniform of the prisoner or as the westerners
think that that of the uniform of the prisoner,
it doesn't matter -- it was.
And President Reagan as he later told me,
President Reagan, when Gorbachev started telling
him, "Let us speak about real issues why you
again you're speaking about all this bunch
of criminals, who they represent. They represent,
nobody exactly what we today say about dissidents.
Reagan took him to the window and said, "You
see you-you know that I know that Sharansky
is not American spy and you know. But you
know after all it doesn't matter," he said.
"My people believe to that lady," he said.
"And as long as she is demonstrating, they
will not trust you. So we-we really have to-to
start from this."
I knew nothing about it.
Three days after this I am in Siberia in punishment
cell again very weak lying on the floor, I
don't have any strength to-to move.
Suddenly they take me from this punishment
cell and move to the hospital. And they start,
to the prison hospital. And they start feeding
me. And they feed me with things which I already
forgot that they exist. When they brought
me eggs, I didn't understand what it is -- for
nine years I didn't see eggs; and meat and
butter and milk, things which I didn't see
these nine years.
Well thank God at that moment I didn't know
that as a Jew I'm not supposed to eat butter
–
[laughter]
and bread or meat together so I ate everything-everything
what they brought me I ate, ate, ate.
One of these days they started giving me injections
of glucose and some special vitamins which
they were injecting me in another and it gave
me a lot of strength. They gave me two hours
of walk every day in the snow and the sun;
in Siberia for half a year I didn't see any
sun.
And suddenly I start feeling a bit myself
stronger and stronger. I could walk, I could
make exercise. I added 15 kilos, now I added
another 20 kilos –
[laughter]
Suddenly, and I was sure that they were preparing
me for another meeting with some KGB leader
from time to time they wanted to do that.
Suddenly well I will not go into details you
can read it in my books but at that moment
they take me from the prison, change my clothes,
put me in the car, take a few hours to the
airport in [ ], and then put me in the airplane.
And huge airplane, 200 seats, only I and four
KGB –
[laughter]
people like in good old days when they were
following me day and night were there for
me and we are flying.
They don't say where.
By sun I see that we go to the West. And so
after some hours it's clear that Soviet Union
is a huge country that also has its [ ]. They
inform me officially in solemn voice that
there is a special decision of Soviet Government
for my bad behavior on behalf Soviet citizenship
I am deprived of Soviet citizenship –
[laughter]
and exiled from Soviet too.
So then I tell them it's such a solemn moment,
I say, "I want to make a statement." They
say, "Oh no, you don't say it, it's enough
you've just spoken up."
[laughter]
But I feel that such a great audience - four
KGB men -- I had to something to say. And
I insist and I say that, "I declare now that
I never was American spy, but I was fighting
for freedom and I hope and I'm sure the day
will come when all 200 million Soviet people
will get freedom as I get it today."
And I say it. I felt it's very important for
me to-to say this. [laughs]
[laughter]
I don't know why it was important for me to
say to them that I'm not American spy, but
it was such an important moment.
And then we landed and I all time looked at
now I will see my wife. And then I see there
is DDR. DDR is German Democratic Republic,
it doesn't exist today. I say, "Oh my God."
Then I will not see her because German Democratic
Republic.
And they tell me, "You see there the car.
We don't --" there is a lot of journalists,
cameras and they say, "We-we don't want to
go out now you will be soon free. You go straight
to that car. Agreed?"
And the moment he said, "Agreed," I said,
"What do you mean, agreed? All these years
I never agreed with you. You tell me to go
straight I'll go zig-zag so."
[laughter]
So they said, well because it was really very
important not to give up on anything to them.
So they say, "Okay." Then, so they went on
two sides to the car and I, as promised, went
zig zag to the car, but shortly speaking,
they took me on the Glienicke Bridge between
Eastern Berlin and Western Berlin which don't
exist today -- between Eastern Germany and
Western Germany -- it doesn't exist today.
Between the world of Communism that doesn't
exist today and the world of freedom.
And there American Ambassador took me through
over the bridge and then I said, "Where is
the border?" He said, "This line is the border."
I-I – And I forgot to say they gave me few
clothes and all it was very big on me as you
can understand. But they didn't give me the
belt because of course prisoners are not supposed
to have belt. So they gave me some rope which
was keeping my pants. So when they said, "There
is the border," I jumped over it. And the
rope broke.
[laughter]
And I get there and each hour they ask, "What
was your first thought when you entered freedom?"
I said, "How not to lose my pants."
[laughter]
[applause]